I've worked at Oracle since 2002 but in
between I spent six years working at the
Klipsch foundation so I don't know if
any of you use the Eclipse IDE or have
any involvement in any Eclipse projects
but I spent a few years in the middle
there I went back to Oracle in 2011 just
after the Sun acquisition had closed and
Oracle was looking at you know we have
Java SE we're trying to integrate this
into the Oracle ethos we need somebody
that understands open source and the the
Java ecosystem this you know understand
you know how Sun Microsystems used to
work and so on
and so that was kind of a great
opportunity for me and and I've been
running Java C product management ever
since ever since then alright so lots
going on in the in the Java ecosystem
you know we've we've been working for
many many years making Java more and
more open constantly driving the
technology we you know we've realized in
the last couple of years we have to be
more nimble at bringing features to
market so we've been working on that and
also scalability so you know we are
seeing statistics about you know people
running trillions of JVMs and running
you know into petabytes of data and so
we need to make sure that our solutions
are scalable so those are kind of the
key the key driving areas before I go
into the slides and go into the the new
release model I do just want to take a
step back and just kind of forget the
slides for a minute and just summarize
there's there's kind of three things
that have been going on in the Java
ecosystem for the last two years and
there are actually independent events
but they can easily get conflated and
confuse
together especially if you want to form
a grand conspiracy and sometimes I wish
I was as smart as people think I am with
these grand conspiracies I assure you
it's not how it works but we so we have
these three separate things so the first
thing and and I'll talk about each of
these things in more detail later but I
just I just want to get that out there
first
number one is we are going through the
end of public updates of Java 8 all
right so what that means and this is
this is an Oracle thing what that means
is Oracle is going to stop making
publicly available free commercial use
updates of Java 8 this is not a new
thing this is the way the Java ecosystem
has worked since well before Oracle and
the Sun era
it's how Java gets funded it's how we
fund the development of the Java
platform so let's travel back in time
you know we have Java 5 released
everybody's using Java 5 Java 6 comes
along after a bit of time son says if
you want Java 5 updates you need to be a
Java for business customer all right and
if you want the free stuff you use Java
6 and then Oracle acquires son we go
through the end of public updates of
Java 6 because Java 7 is available and
the headlines are Oracle starts charging
for Java you know the worst fear that we
were all at you know expecting when
Oracle bought sun that they're going to
start charging for Java the end of
public updates of Java 6 and pushing
people on to Java 7 was exactly the same
pattern that Sun had been going on
before you know we cannot afford to
maintain updates for free for eight
different releases of Java right we have
to draw a line somewhere and so the
current stuff is free the old stuff if
you want to stay on the legacy releases
because you
have a nap in production that's where we
want to monetize right and that has been
the business model for a very long time
so we're going through that right now
with Java 8 it's a little different with
Java 8 because of some of the stuff with
the desktop so we are still going to
provide free updates of Java 8 for
consumers and individuals for developers
testing QA but not for production
commercial use right so it's it's end of
public updates except if you are in one
of those other categories so Java 8 okay
so that's the first thing that's
happening we are going through this
long-standing practice of end of public
updates of Java the second thing that's
happening is we've changed the release
cadence so we used to have these massive
releases with hundreds of spec changing
features every what we would say two
years but it was always every three to
four years and sometimes five right and
that worked well in the 90s and it
worked well in the early 2000s and even
this recently is 2010 it was probably
still okay to have a release cadence in
the three-year time timeframe as a
platform but with modern application
development with continuous integration
continuous deployment methodologies with
the cloud and mobile taking hold there's
just no way for Java to continue its
relevance for the next decade if we were
on these three-year long release cadence
right it's just it's table stakes I'm
unapologetic about switching to a six
month release cadence we talked about a
six month release cadence four years at
open JDK with all the contributors to
open JDK at the JCP because we had to
streamline what was a multi-year JCP
spec process into a six month iterative
process so that took a lot of
conversations and everybody agreed and
open JDK and with the JCP that this made
a
lot of sense to keep Java relevant for
the next 10 years so that's the second
thing that happens is we is we've
changed the release cadence right and so
it's created a bit of confusion with
with end of public updates which would
have been a fairly routine thing with
the new release cadence and as part of
that oracle has open sourced and is
producing open JDK releases rather than
having this binary code license that we
used to have so you may recall for its
it's a it's literally a 15 year old
license the the BCL you may have heard
of the general general purpose computer
clause the field of use restrictions in
that license it was sometimes free
sometimes commercial and we we realized
a year or two ago this doesn't make
sense why are we releasing Java under
this semi free semi commercial license
when we could just release an open JDK
build under the GPL so starting a couple
years ago we started producing the
Oracle JDK under the licensing regime
that has existed for a very long time
the BCL and commercial use but we
started to produce open JDK builds with
a goal of getting those together to be
the same binary that we would either
distribute to our commercial customers
under a commercial license because they
don't want to deal with the GPL or as
open source as an open JDK release so
we're there now so we produce if you go
to JDK Java net you will get Oracle's
open JDK builds under the GPL so you
don't have to worry about the BCL you
don't have to worry about am i running
this in a dedicated purpose device is
this really is the cloud a
general-purpose computer I don't know
you don't have to worry about any of
that stuff right it's just that it's the
same license as Linux right and then so
yeah so we moved to open source all the
closed commercial stuff that we had so
we had
flight recorder mission control we had a
bunch of performance enhancements that
we had kept in the Oracle JDK only
around class data sharing we were
working on a deterministic garbage
collector that was originally conceived
as being a closed source commercial
feature but we've open-sourced that as
zgc or Zed GC what do you say here is
that or Z Z said doesn't matter yeah so
so yeah so we've open sourced all that
but then the the third thing that we did
so end of public updates of Java 8 new
release cadence and hope Oracle open
sourcing all of the close stuff that it
had before as open JDK builds and then
the third thing is we introduced a
subscription product so remember I
mentioned son used to have this product
called Java for business and then when
Oracle acquired son it was rebranded in
the set of this Java for business it was
called Java SE advanced and it was sold
by the Oracle middleware team you see
this is one of these things where if I
wasn't being recorded I would tell you
some things about the Oracle middleware
sales team but basically it's a
perpetual I've seen some let the records
show that there's some knowing nods in
the back of the room but but basically
this is a perpetually licensed product
it has a high cost there's a lot of
negotiation and then you pay annual
support and maintenance on top of that
and that worked great until a few years
ago when it became clear the way modern
applications and systems by software is
by a subscription so we used to have
this $5,000 a processor license with 22%
annual maintenance and support that's
how we used to sell the Java support
business right that's how we if you
wanted to stay on Java 6 and pay Oracle
to give you those updates that's how we
used to do it ok we've transitioned to a
subscription model it's $25 a processor
a month right we've gotten rid of the
old perpetual
since we've gone to a subscription model
and the reason for that is very simple
it's how people want to buy software now
it aligns with how you buy your Linux
support if you buy Linux support if you
buy Linux support you can now buy Java
support following the exact same model
and again it's 25 bucks versus 5 grand
but that gets perceived as you know
Oracle is now starting to charge for
Java and it's like we haven't we've it
simplified how we charge for Java for
those that care right so those are the
three things now let me kind of go
through the slides and visualize a lot
of this stuff any questions on that at
the risk of potentially rattling before
I even get into the slides we're good ok
and I should probably pay attention to
the time right
Pizza who do you order your pizza from
mother made here ok in the university
her college okay all right so let's look
at the release the the release model so
I got some I have one of the guys on my
team has way too much time on his hands
sometimes but I have to admit we've
presented this series of slide
animations about a thousand times and so
it's it's kind of paid off because it is
a good visualization but so this was the
the JDK release model plan the plan
always was we would do a release every
two years right and that's always been
our intent and what you may not have
noticed unless you're really really
paying attention or if like if you're an
IT manager you you may have noticed this
a little more particularly but within
that two-year cadence we have actually
always had a six-month cadence of up
feature updates so when we released Java
8 it was like five five months in a
couple weeks later we did eight u20
which had a bunch of features in it and
then seven months later just shy of
seven months later we did eight you
forty
and then shortly after that we did eight
you sixty and so on and we're at eight
you two hundred and something now we've
always had the six month cadence of
features with security updates
interleaved in there every quarter so we
do for security coordinated security
updates every year and so like I said
we've always had that six-month cadence
behind the scenes you just may not have
noticed because you may have just picked
this stuff up as part of your normal
security baseline management so when we
launched Java 8 this was this was our
vision of the future was you know in a
couple years we would release Java 9 we
would change the version numbering of
course because hey you know why not see
there's another one I could go on a
little bit of a rant on but I won't
because we're being recorded but yeah so
we're not again this was this was our
vision but of course you know things
things get delayed huge features that
are you're trying to bind to a
particular release version need to be
delayed for one reason or another
whether it's your own challenges with
you know the new features and the
technology or whether it's you maybe
have partners or licensees or other
companies who are terrified of the
change and are demanding behind the
scenes for extra extra time things slip
right and so we end up making these
three three to four year time frames and
again you may not have noticed but
behind the scenes we after we do a
release we have a six-month release
lined up right behind it with some new
features that go along with it and so it
begs the question and I'm gonna just
flip back and forth on this animation a
couple times just to try to draw a point
here I've been saying eight you 28 you
forty were feature updates and they
absolutely were there was new things
added but there was never a spec
changing feature meaning we could not
introduce a feature
that required the JCP to approve a new
specification because you have to go
through this whole JCP process with the
expert groups the expert committee has
to vote on it of course if you're adding
an API or changing an API you're gonna
have a lot of different opinions on how
that should look and what the impact
would be and so on and so forth
so we could never do we could never do
spec changing up updates and what we
said was well you know again if we want
Java to be relevant for the next ten
years in a world where we have node in a
world where we have go in a world where
we have Swift in a world where we have
Scala okay I don't have to sorry I don't
have to name off every programming
language but my point is there's a lot
of competition out there right and so if
we want to remain relevant we knew we
had to work with the JCP to streamline
that process and also with especially
with the folks at open JDK who work with
us on those releases to make sure that
we could do the spec changing features
if we so chose on a six month cadence
right alright so basically the plan is
what we're gonna do is those six month
updates we're just gonna run them
through the the JCP process we're gonna
we're going to in terms of getting a
specification a reference implementation
a technology compatibility kit and all
that all that kind of work what we're
gonna do is streamline things and be
able to do that and that and that's what
we did now we we realize that you know
we look carefully at some of the linux
vendors and how they do long-term
support we look at Firefox and how they
do long-term support right Firefox is
another product by the way if you go
back in time and look at they changed
their release cadence as well it's very
it's we learned a lot watching what they
had done when they transitioned from
their release cadence to their current
model where they increment the main
version number of fire
phox it seems like every second week
right yeah so we but you know we
realized we wanted to have at least one
version every so often every three years
seems about right that we would
designate as a long term support release
meaning that one won't get feature
updates ever like after you do the you
do the release then you do security
updates stability performance updates as
needed but no new features the features
just go into the six month cadence still
and that is for the conservative folk
that want to stay behind on a legacy
release like Java six or Java Java five
okay so if we throw it out in in time a
little bit you can see we're targeting
Java eleven is going to be a long term
support release and again this is from
an Oracle point of view if some other
company wants to declare a job at 12 is
a long term support release they are
more than welcome to do that
right but we're declaring Java eleven is
a long term support release for our
customers and we're targeting seventeen
which is three years later hey you know
when we get to this point here maybe
we'll look at the market and decide
maybe we should pull it in a little bit
there's a need or maybe we'll push it
out a little bit but you know three
years feels about right so if we put the
the kind of the historical timelines on
there you can see that the long-term
support release is kind of mirror the
old model we had where you know you can
either get on the six month release
cadence and always get everything for
free get the security updates for free
easy to do keep up or if you want it to
stay behind on Java seven or Java six
you would have commercial support
options for that all right now simple
that's color coded a little bit here so
the color coding here just goes into
some of the license pedantry here I'm
happy to deep dive if anybody wants
wants to do
although I find in a room like this and
slides like this it's not the best way
to do it we can whiteboard during the
break or after the fact but but what
this slide here is trying to convey is
going forward Oracle is producing open
JDK builds they are very high quality
they are as high quality is the Oracle
JDK builds that we produce under the GPL
on a six-month cadence with security
updates so we do a release it gets two
security updates we do a release it gets
two security updates
there's over overlaps in there so that
you do have time to transition between
ten and eleven and twelve and thirteen
the early access program has been
greatly bolstered so you know it's we
have a release candidate for Java 12
that's been there for several weeks
already
Java 12 GA s in a couple weeks you could
have already gotten a jump on what is
almost certainly going to be the the GA
bit so there's lots of time to overlap
there and manage that the red stuff is
where we have the commercial long term
support option with a Java SE
subscription and the green bit there is
is conveying the fact that we're keeping
Java eight free for consumers so if you
have you know some sort of desktop app
as an individual you can continue to use
that under the the license that we will
release in April okay and then I put a
different loops put a different
perspective on this so you know so
basically you're either going to just
keep up with with the release cadence
just like you keep up with your Firefox
releases every every couple of weeks or
you can if you if you wish to you can
get on a long-term support release and
still get commercially those same bits
as we have on the six month cadence
all right any questions on this slide
before I go ahead maybe I should have
asked this ten minutes ago but is this
new information or is this stuff you
guys already knew or is this is this
helpful I'm not asking if you like it
okay let the record show they laughed
okay thank you okay so you know again
we've been working hard in an open JDK
to make Java more open we were on a path
like I say up through the Java 8 release
where we had a group that was working on
closed source features and we were gonna
have a closed Oracle JDK that had you
know value add you know we realized
that's that's not a good way forward so
we've worked hard to move things into
the open I think I have some slides on
some specifics coming up so when when we
talk about the new release cadence it's
really hard to wrap wrap your mind
around if if you have struggled and I
know like I know I've struggled I'm sure
you have too if you struggled moving
from Java 6 to Java 7 or if you
struggled moving my last big struggle
was moving from Java 4 to Java 5
generics oh my god why do we need
generics in a platform you know son
killed Java Java 5 because of the
complexity of generics that's like
actually you can go back and find all
kinds of articles about how it's that
was the end of Java but but my point
there is on these major releases we had
you know I wish we went further back in
time because there was actually like
hundreds of major changes so it's it's
always been a challenge to keep up but
under the new release cadence we haven't
magically quadrupled our development
organization and our ability to code
features
what we're doing is instead of releasing
hundreds of changes at once we're just
doing it on a more incremental basis
right and we if we had a slide here that
showed like here if we showed eight you
20 and 8 you 40 it's it's actually this
like the same number as we're seeing in
10 11 and 12 so you know my point is
when we talk about the release cadence
when you hear about going from Java 10
to 11 it sounds scary right it's like oh
my gosh that's a major release but it's
not a major release we're shifting the
language Java 9 was the last major
release the releases after that are
feature releases and they're just
six-month feature releases now that
being said moving to Java 9 is very
challenging right there's there's it's
probably the most challenging migration
if you're before Java and I if you're
still on Java 8 or 7 and you want to
move to Java 9 plus it's really
challenging and the reason I'll have
more slides on this later but but the
reason is just there was a number of
changes not only with jigsaw but you
know because of jigsaw we were able to
improve some of the security and
accessibility that we were exposing
through Sun miss gun safe and so you
know depending on what third-party lie
even if you weren't using Sun miss gun
safe some libraries you depend on may
have been and we spent a couple years
trying to coax those frameworks along
and had some success but nevertheless
you know it's it's still an effort but
I'm I'm greatly encouraged by once
people make the move to Java 9 or you
know move to 10 or 11 how the
transitions have been so far it's been
great so one thing I've noticed is the
IDE
right so I'm I was an eclipse guy at one
point so I pay very close attention to
what IDs are doing
and it's really encouraging to see for
example IntelliJ already supports the
new stuff in Java 12 right before it
before it's even GA and so what I'm
hearing is from some friends at eclipse
is it was always a huge panic in the
last two or three months of a major
release because you know first of all
the Eclipse folks had to figure out well
is Oracle gonna slip the GA date like do
we you know do we yeah how much time do
we actually have or like do we have two
months or do we have fourteen months
right and you know we would send signals
it's like no no we are like absolutely
giing on the state and then it's like oh
crap like we have all these new features
that we have to be able to support
because look how many features there are
right so a lot of those are IDE changing
things and so be this huge panic huge
effort you'd have to pull in a couple of
dozen people with varying skill sets all
over the place
work on it and then they wouldn't have
to do anything for two or three years
right and all that knowledge we got lost
so this way it's it's much more
dedicated it's much more routine it's
extremely predictable if for example we
get a feature we had a feature targeted
for Java 12 raw string literals and we
had a preview release of it it was
targeted for Java 12 and we just we got
some really strong feedback from folks
that it's we're not ready for this like
you forgot about this case that edge
case you know what if you have four oh
man I must be really tired I'm
forgetting the word for a tick ' yeah
yes so you know it allows us to just
kind of jettison that stuff and just
move it defer it to to another release
right so the idea is now we have a you
know much more digestible release
cadence and the tool the tools ecosystem
has to go from
you know this three-year every three
year or so panic to realizing they have
to keep up and do much more routine
maintenance I assure you it's the same
amount of effort but it's now
distributed more evenly right and I
think in the long term that's going to
be a huge win but it's a change right
and and I know I know a lot of
organizations have to have to change
have to make make these changes and that
takes effort so but again I'm really
excited by how well this is working so
far so hopefully we can continue that
momentum and when we're at Java 16 we'll
it'll just be routine at that point and
we'll be telling our children about that
time we have all had to move to Javan 9
or later so ok so let's go through some
of these releases and a little more
detail about what was in them by the way
how many people here are actually
running Java 9 or later ok so there's a
few folks but so most of you I assume
are on Java 8 anybody on Java 7 so a
couple anybody on Java 6 or earlier
willing to admit it ok that's good news
yeah Java 6 is it is officially
end-of-life so there are there are no
more updates available to Java 6 and
that was as of Christmas all right
so but here if you so if you look at the
the JDK 9 feature list you can see it's
why it's a challenge to move to write
like those are all the Jets the JDK
enhancement proposal there's like
hundreds of changes that you need to
consider okay so that was a huge huge
update now job at nine one of the you
know if you ask a hundred Java
developers what's new in Java nine
ninety of them will reply jigsaw right
and the other ten will I don't know
it's gonna say something but I'm being
recorded so yeah so but the fact is only
these are jigsaw related like so so my
point there is there's actually a heck
of a lot more in Java 9 than just the
module system modularity so there's a
lot of a lot of other things went into
that release Java 10 one year ago it was
our first time bound release and it only
had a dozen gems
ok now if you look at those jep's I
don't know if if you can see that I do
have slides on a couple of those at some
point but as an example like one of the
Jets is at root certificates as open
source so Oracle had a root certificate
program but it was commercial only it
was only in the Oracle JDK people who
were viewing open JDK builds had to find
their own root certificates and often
what they would do is just steal them
from Firefox or do something in the
operating system and so it seems silly
for Oracle to have its own proprietary
set of root certificates and so we
worked with the root certificate vendors
that we have relationships with and we
said we're going to open-source these
and they all say it fine because they
want to be used in as many J decays as
possible but but my point there is that
like that's a [ __ ] but that's not going
to make it more difficult to migrate if
anything it's going to make it easier
for you to migrate and if not now
certainly down the road so so there are
some Jepson here that are spec changing
so the local variable type interface for
example is something that you know had
to be carefully looked at IDs and tool
chains had to consider what what it
would take to adapt to it and they did
so there's a couple there and that was a
good proof point we were we were very
sensitive to what that first set of Japs
was going to be to kind of show that
people that move to Java 9 would be able
to slowly make those transitions another
thing you'll see starting in Java 10 is
our work on docker so we realized that
Java is running in containers more and
more and more and so we've been working
hard to provide api's and settings to
make sure that Java works well in a in a
docker I store containerized world it's
often it's often about the boot it's a
boot how the the jdk interacts with
either the the host operating system or
the or the container manager for things
like processes and memory we also have
Alpine support so you can download
Alpine Linux builds from Oracle of the
our open JDK builds we don't
commercially support that at least not
yet but it's just kind of a proof point
of an area of investigation that were
we're pretty pretty serious about so
you'll see features related to that
starting in Java 10 and again so this is
an example of a spec changing feature
that we would have otherwise had to wait
for three years at least to release
right we released Java 9 this feature
wasn't going to make it until Java 10
three years later if we didn't change
the release cadence right and so this is
mostly for readability but it's
basically the ability to use a keyword
var instead of having to fully type
everything so when the type can be
inferred you can just use var and it's
one of those things where language
purists will spend a lot far too much
time and in my opinion debating the
semantics of this and whether it's good
or not for
language but you know when you see
community leaders like Lukas say you
know I've only been using this for a
couple of weeks and I can't remand
without it that's that's a good sign and
nobody's forcing you to use it you don't
have to use far if you don't that's my
always my always my spoke is going a
little crazy with the exhaustion yeah
that's my point is some of these
features you can have a strong opinion
on but we're not making you useless so
all right so you know this slide would
be here if somebody was jumping up and
telling me that var was a horrible
addition to the Java platform nobody's
doing that you all seem pretty chill
here so that's good but you know what
one sorry we stole it from JavaScript
okay yeah so so you know one of the
language guys on our team
likes to point out that if you're
worried about the readability because
you use var and you're not sure what the
types are gonna be like if you're
looking at a code review is like you
should name your variables better if
it's okay so you know these slides I
will certainly make available you know
so like I'm not going to spend I have 70
or 80 slides so we're not gonna spend
too much time on each one yeah so
application class data sharing and again
this was something we were working on as
a as a commercial feature that we open
sourced as part of the new release
cadence and building open JDK releases
instead of this weird license we used to
have and so basically with the way class
data sharing works is it will ahead of
time create a file that knows all of the
class information and it can just load
that up a lot faster at startup so that
it doesn't have to compute everything
ahead of time or sorry compute
everything on the fly
so yeah so that's that's a good feature
we see lots of good feedback from folks
all over the place that are really happy
that they have apps EDS cuz it again it
improves the startup time of an app that
you're going to be running over and over
again you know in the EE world something
like apps EDS it's like yeah you know I
start my app server every 2 or 3 weeks
it's not that big of a deal if it takes
an extra minute to startup but in the
world of containers in the world of
functions as a service in the world of
continuous integration and deployment
something like app CDSs is really
important so also in Java 10 we saw an
experimental Java based JIT called growl
well actually it's yeah
and so that is available this is the we
should have somebody from the growl team
come in and do or has maybe somebody
from the Braille team has already come
in no you know remember has anybody
heard of crawl before all right yeah we
got a few folks there yeah so so growl
is a product that's being developed in
Oracle labs and it's virtual virtual
machine high performance technology
they're a OT but one of the one of the
benefits of their research from Oracle
labs is they have a JIT that's written
in Java and so we can take that JIT
compiler use it in in our open JDK and
Oracle JDK releases and we can see
better inlining and performance because
of that all right and yeah at at Q Khan
I saw a couple of sessions where people
were talking about their use of growl
it's it can be overwhelming actually for
certain very certain specific kinds of
benchmarks so you know we've seen third
parties like charlie
on the JRuby team he's a big fan of some
of the performance benchmarking that he
was able to to get and again and again
it's it's not that it's 10% faster it's
like it's overwhelmingly faster right
for certain types of applications so we
have that experimental jet you can try
it today right it's just part of every
JDK release after 10 or starting with 10
ok how are we doing on time sorry 10
minutes ok good I think there will be a
logical point coming up soon all right
so another thing that we've been working
on around the java 10 timeframe is
consolidating the jdk forests and this
is I don't presume anybody here is
active in open JDK as a committer or an
author right but you know we have
several hundred people that work
everyday in the open JDK source repos
its mercurial based right which made
sense a long time ago
and it still makes a lot of sense in a
lot of ways today
but we do realize at some point we're
probably going to want to transition
that and so we've been you know we have
a project at open JDK called sclera
where they're investigating you know
other source control management systems
and as part of that we consolidated how
we've set up and managed the mercurial
repos that we use which may seem like
well how does that benefit me as a Java
user it makes it it makes our release
cadence more predictable and it will
allow us in the longer term to produce
higher and higher quality releases on
that new cadence all right so that
brings us to Java 11 which was released
in September Java 11 is the current
release Java 12 comes out in a couple
weeks and Java 11 had 17 Jets and you
know again another example of a spec
changing feature that we would have had
to wait years for but we can now get a
get to market very quickly and that's
TLS 1.3 right so I would not it would
have been an awkward thing to have to
because TLS 1-3 wasn't ready when Java 9
g8 and it would have been awful for the
Java ecosystem to have to wait years
before we were able to get TLS 1 3 out
so that's another proof point of the new
release cadence and the value of it all
right so building Java 11 together so
this this is just an homage to all the
organizations and individuals there's a
lot of individuals that don't show up
here
necessarily but this is more about the
organizations that contribute to open
JDK so this is just looking at the Java
11 release s AP is one of the biggest
contributors to open JDK you don't hear
about them a lot a lot of their
contributions are based on specific
ports for their I think some I want to
say PPC or AIX this is ed 390 like those
types of systems where they have they
have customers that have like 50 years
support horizons
you know like airplane companies and
such so they're they're active primarily
on that front but but also most
certainly in a lot of other ways Red Hat
is also a huge contributor to to open
JDK relative to all the other
organizations and I can't remember if I
have slides on this explicitly so let me
just take a minute to explain
so in in openjdk and this has been true
since 2009 so it predates the
acquisition of Sun Microsystems so Sun
and Red Hat had this format from years
ago
wherein openjdk when we end of public
updates let's let's use Java six
actually because I was probably the
first first one end of public updates of
Java six the source code is all there on
open JDK Oracle stops making public
releases of Java six of you so it
becomes a support only thing but Red Hat
continues to produce open JDK builds of
Java six and for their customers and
their users and what they're doing is in
conjunction with Oracle they're working
with us they're back porting the work
that we are making available with the
security updates and continuing open JDK
six and now they've are supporting open
JDK 7 and actually now that I remember I
do have a slide on this coming up but
they will be taking over open JDK 8
right so that allows Oracle to continue
focusing on innovation and the current
releases and moving forward and Red Hat
helps keep those open JDK projects going
and again working with us and the
vulnerability working group to back port
those issues so that's why you see them
show up there Google they also provide
fixes mostly so they're big into garbage
collection so we all will often get
fixes and stuff from them on that oh I
guess we did count independent people
there's about 40 or so and then you know
the long tail of of other other
companies working in open JDK
all right yeah so we're talking about
Java
11
how has the audio been good I'm not too
loud okay good
all right
are we good okay all right so welcome
back and for those of you that are
watching this online you missed out on
pizza it was delicious
so who will will pick it up oh and it
was from grid games so thank you grid
gain for the for the pizza yeah so so
we're gonna pick up with Java 11 I'm
just gonna go through you know some of
the features that the more interesting
of the the features that made Java 7 and
I went through earlier and talked about
all the contributors so one of the new
things in Java 11 is the ability to
basically execute a single Java file so
you can set it up that you double click
on a Java file and it'll execute it or
if you're into command lines you can go
and set it up that you can just run a
single Java file and the main motivation
for this is you know we want to become
the next greatest scripting platform
over Python so no that's not the
motivation although based on some of the
visceral feedback that people had over
this feature you would swear that that
that was the belief of what we were
doing
no really it's it's just about trying to
be approachable to new programmers you
know just creating a simple way to be
able to just simply run a Java file and
not worry about the compile step and
just make it easier to experiment and
play around so has anybody here you use
J shell which was introduced in Java 9
the so in Java 9 we had a new feature
called J shell which is a read event
print loop repple and it also made makes
java quite approachable because you
basically get a command line and you're
able to to code java right
right on a prompt on a command line and
try snippets of code really really
easily so I use that a lot especially if
I'm doing demos so this is just it's
another one of those things in that vein
just making it easier for for developers
to pick up okay also in Java 11 we we
release the HTTP client as GA so it had
been incubating for a little bit
it supports HTTP 2 so it just makes it
easier for those of you that are writing
HTTP based apps again
TLS 1/3 an important security overhaul
that didn't make the Java 9 release
because it wasn't ready at the the spec
the TLS 1/3 spec so as soon as that was
finalized we were able to make that
available in the next Java release and
so it's in Java 11 so you have access to
some more modern cryptography algorithms
and it also obsoletes some of the some
of the older stuff that hopefully you're
not still using if you're into
cryptography if you do do a lot of
security network traffic and
applications I would recommend you
follow the Java crypto roadmap and we
actually host that on Java comm mostly
you know normally our developer focused
content goes on OTN but this one we
wanted to draw a special attention to so
if you just google for the Java crypto
java cryptography roadmap we give you
lots and lots of warning of when specs
are coming along when we're going to
deprecated some some older protocols as
the security industry deems them as no
longer being safe so we try to give lots
of warning as that's happening
and the cryptography roadmap it's a good
a good place for that this this nest
based access control is one of those
features where I'm like I you know I I'm
shocked that it's not important but it
you know our our architects and language
designers and platform designers you
know they they see you know they say
benefit at scale at some of these
seemingly trivial things so so basically
with this the way inner classes were
managed and created prior to Java 11
used a few extra bytes that weren't
necessary so you know in our relentless
pursuit of continually optimizing for
performance and memory it was realized
that we could take you know a fairly
common inner class scenario like this
and reduce the number of bytes fairly
significantly right so it's like 20
percent fewer bytes on the on the person
class there and that adds up at scale
and it adds up if you're doing a lot of
coding that ends up having inner classes
rights but if you're doing a lot of
lambda related work you're gonna get
some compactness out of this feature you
don't have to do anything it just
automatically it's taken care of for you
also with Java 11 we open sourced Java
flight recorder so this used to be a
commercial feature so you used to pay
for this and now it's just part of the
JDK and Oracle open JDK and any other
folks that take the open JDK builds from
us
anybody here by the way use flight
recorder or Mission Control that one
person so if you haven't looked at this
you really should right so I can
understand if you were reluctant to look
at it before as a commercial feature but
now that it's free and part of open JDK
the
no reason for you enough to have a look
at this so it's it's always on and
because it's in you know it's because
it's an integral part of the the JVM
it's very low overhead so the the goal
is that I will never introduce more than
one percent performance and if you run
into a problem in production and you've
had the flight recording turned on
you'll get a tremendous amount of
information out of that so that's also
new in Java 11 it's not a new thing it's
new that it's free and it's new that
it's open source basically so in Java 11
we also introduced zgc this a
deterministic garbage collector although
I guess we're not supposed to call it a
deterministic garbage collector because
it's not deterministic so the goal the
goal here is to get as close to zero
garbage collection pause times as
possible and we've actually been working
on this for a long time the the the
developers for this for are the same
developers that worked on j-rock at real
time does anybody remember Jay rocket I
don't know if any of you were using DEA
and WebLogic but another company that
Oracle acquired and so yeah so they've
been working on that for a good while
and we're now seeing the the fruits of
that all right in the interest of time I
won't spend too much time on this it's
just faster so I we have a I'll mention
this I think I have a couple more slides
on some other features that are coming
in Java 12 but you have a number of
garbage collection options which i think
is a good thing because every every
application has a different performance
characteristic to it so being able to
have some choice over how you
your garbage collection I think is a
good thing so we have 0 GC which is
experimental you can try that out like a
you know we have well that's weird
lots of folks have been have been
banging on this for a while and are
seeing some some amazing stats depending
on the type of application as you may
know G 1 GC was an experimental garbage
collector in Java 8 and one of the
updates and we made that as the default
garbage collector for Java 9 and later
there is in Java 12 coming a garbage
collector designed by Red Hat called
shenandoah which also has some some real
time like characteristics so I think
it's good that we're seeing some
competition as to who can make their
garbage collector the you know the the
least pause the least and then we were
just talking at the break about a
garbage collector called epsilon which
is basically it just turns garbage
collection off entirely so if you have
an application where you know you're
it's gonna be so short-lived or you're
gonna run a benchmark where you know you
have a fixed amount of memory and it's
no big deal
where you have some time based app where
you have lots of memory and you know
it's not going to be a big deal you can
just plug in epsilon garbage collector
and not have to deal with any pauses
whatsoever
so though you know lots of interesting
things happening there in the garbage
collection space so when we released
Java 9 some benchmarks got some
benchmarks were slower than we had seen
in Java 8 but there were some benchmarks
that were definitely faster so there was
a bit of trade-off and balancing going
on and we knew that when we when we G
aid and a lot of this was related to
some of the work and improvements on
lambdas behind the scenes and so yeah so
we can see though that with the Java 11
release the benchmarks
you know all of the performance
benchmarks that we see are far superior
than Java 8 so if you're still running
on Java 8 and you haven't run a Java 11
runtime a VM and runtime on it you
should and you may be pleasantly
surprised at how much more performance
it is all right so all right so this is
about migrating to Java 11 and sorry if
the this is a bit what's the word I'm
looking for trite trite it's not a word
trite trite yeah but is it the word I
hope it means I hope I'm not saying
something insulting but smug
maybe smug you know but but basically if
you're looking to migrate to Java 11
read the documentation so there's a
couple of things right so one of the
perceptions is well with jigsaw and
modules I have to modularize my
application now going forward is like no
you don't like you you really shouldn't
have to make a lot of changes to your
code if any have a look at the
documentation and it will highlight what
what the changes are so some some things
you want to keep your eye out for is if
you were using Sun Miskin safe
you're probably gonna have some troubles
migrating from 8 to it to a later
release but once you do that you're
gonna be good there was a lot of things
deprecated in and actually removed in 9
and later but especially later so 10 and
11 so if you were using some of the EE
libraries like Jax some of the Jax
libraries we had some CORBA has been
removed you're going to have to do this
extra step of downloading those and
adding them as a separate module ok and
you know there's lots of examples of
that
so so that's another area you might want
to look at as part of your migration and
so you know there's a bunch of tools
that are available online as well where
they can look at your code we provide
tools so we have a tool called Jade EPS
and have a slide on this coming up Jade
I always forget the name of the second
one
Jade app our Jade Jade upper usually if
somebody in the audience helps me out
with this but not not gonna happen
okay too full of pizza yeah so so we
have tools that will help you analyze
your code and print out you know here
are things that are have been deprecated
or are scheduled to be deprecated and
we're taking deprecation a lot more
seriously going forward because we know
as a platform we have to remain as light
and nimble as we can you know to remain
competitive in the cloud
yeah so in addition to the obvious steps
when the the process we like to
recommend if you have a chance if the
cue con videos from this week go live or
you might be able to find it somewhere
else online Trisha ghee how you guys
know Trisha right she's part of the ljc
she has spoken here I'm sure she did a
talk yesterday talking very exactly this
process right so her first hint her
first suggestion is just try to run your
program on Java 11 and you may be
pleasantly surprised you will very
quickly learn whether you need to update
the libraries that you have but you may
also be pleasantly surprised that they
are working just fine in my experience
the more tied you were to the Sun Miskin
safe
class the more work you may have to do
here the more libraries you may need to
update but up but otherwise it's
actually not as scary as it sounds so
once you get your application running
you know look
the warnings that have been generated
and pay attention to them we actually
you know we we often get feedback in the
support organization that you know how
do I put this
yeah if it wasn't being recorded so
believe it or not like people rely
something like they have build and test
systems that actually rely on us
generating warning warning them that an
API is being removed and then when we
remove the API it's not that we remove
the API hey it's that the warning
doesn't get generated anymore so all
right those funnier in my head alright
so yeah and and by the way let me just
go back here so another thing to keep in
mind here is you're doing those first
three steps without even compiling it to
Java eleven right like so you're just
I'm just talking about running the class
files as they are right because that
should just work fine and only after you
you have done hopefully not too much
heavy lifting and and moved your
application up from eight then you can
look at compiling and then looking at
the compiling errors or warnings that
you might get at that point all right
so people will ask me well should I move
from eight to nine and then go from nine
to ten and then ten to eleven or
whatever and it's like well you could do
it that way but if I were you I would
move just straight from eight to eleven
the the extra work that you're gonna
have to do is you're just gonna have to
read a couple of sets of release notes
one huge set of release notes for Java
nine and then a couple of small release
notes for ten and eleven and the analogy
I like to use there is when you migrate
it from Java six to Java eight or from
Java seven to Java 8 I hope you migrated
to the latest version of eight at that
time whether it was eight you twenty or
a
you forty or eight you sixty I hope you
didn't go to eight and then go to eight
you twenty or forty or sixty right it
seems seems unnecessary so yeah so
that's that's what I would recommend is
just jump straight into the latest
release whether it's eleven or if you
don't get to it this week twelve and
again I'm not sure how much this would
apply to you folk here but it's it it
would really benefit you to keep an eye
on the open JDK project so it's just
open JDK java.net there are a number of
mailing lists and resources that are
available there to help you keep track
of what's what's coming in the future
releases when people ask me what's
what's coming in Java 13 I just go to to
open JDK to the Java 13 page I don't
have to interact with the developers all
the time asking them what's in and
what's out because it's all updated in
real time and we do that because we are
working with developers from a number of
organizations all of whom will have an
opinion on what should or should not be
part of a release so that's my
recommendation is if you're keen on
keeping up with with what's coming and
what we're working on is open JDK
java.net we have an open JDK Twitter
handle that's also a good resource to
follow that'll give you very targeted
JDK related information we of course
have the at Java Twitter handle but that
is it's a little more broad so it covers
Java as as an entire ecosystem so you'll
get a ear elated stuff and you'll get
all kinds of updates developer stories
and stuff so it's a good channel if
you're up for that but if you're just
specifically interested in the JDK
follow the open JDK Twitter handle
all right so yep so the updates so if
you're used to getting your JD case from
OTN that's cool you can keep doing that
but you'll notice we're also encouraging
you to just get the GPL versions of our
binary from OpenJDK so this is sorry I
spoke at a sequence I was explaining to
you what why you should go to open JDK
and JDK java.net and now I have the
slides that show that but you can see
it's very very simple very
straightforward download page exactly
like you'd expect on a high quality
open-source project and this is the
slide I refer to this earlier where I
was talking about the updates project so
again we've been working in open JDK
since 2008 when Oracle acquired Sun it
doubled down on open JDK as as a place
to work on the reference implementation
and source code of java SE and so when
we went through the end of public
updates of Java 8 back in 20 or sorry
Java 6 back in 2012 or 13 we handed the
project over and you so you could see
that Oracle had worked on the six
updates project and did that amount of
work and then we handed it over and Red
Hat said yeah we'll take over the
updates of this project you go work on
Java 7 and Java 8 and then at some point
Red Hat said ok we're done with Java 6
so Red Hat stop supporting Java 6 a few
years ago and they hand it over to a
company called a Zul and as well took
over the Java 6 updates project so this
this pattern of working on the updates
and transitioning the leadership has
been around for a very very long time
so yeah so if you're interested I don't
know if anybody here is interested in
the actual names of the people actually
andrew haley was at the conference
yesterday and
we hung out for a bit so it's all good
community stuff that has been going on
for a very long time
all right so we have this long-standing
transition process of handing handing
over a project we send emails about it
okay I can tell nobody cares
all right so let's look for those of you
watching online if you're still watching
online nobody cared about that so we'll
move on all right so let's talk about
Java 12 so Java 12 is going to be
released in a couple of weeks but you
know spoiler alert the release candidate
that's there now we are literally just
going to rename it as the release right
so you are barring some you know you
know p0 or some other knock on wood
issue inland in the next week or two so
yeah
so for all intents and purposes Java
Java 12 is is good to go you can see we
have eight jep's including an
experimental JEP and we are sorry a
preview JEP and then of course we have
the experimental jump which I was
talking about shenandoah the garbage
collector so let's go into a little more
detail all right so this this feature
that's coming in Java 12 is basically
releasing memory back to the operating
system which is not something most open
JDK and Oracle JDK builds ever dead so
most Oracle JDK and open JDK builds when
it claimed memory from the operating
system it never gave it back right so if
your heap grew to a certain point and
then it shrunk and you never really need
it that that memory the operating system
doesn't get it back
so starting with you have a 12 we have a
feature where we will be we will be
giving the memory back to the operating
system so if you have a bursty
application that bursts up a huge heap
and needs a whole bunch of memory and
then it calms down and doesn't need all
that memory again you can give it back
to Chrome all right so yeah so you know
I know there's been some experiments
with this over the years there's there's
some VMS and some folks that do this to
varying degrees of success but it's now
going to be just standard part of open
JDK
so that's good the class data sharing
feature so you remember a few slides ago
I can't even remember if it was before
or after the break I was telling you
that you could basically do all the
class loading type behavior ahead of
time and store it so that you could
instantly recall it well why don't we do
that for the JDK by default right so
starting with Java 12 for the 64-bit
platforms we're just going to have
computed the class data set up so that
when you start up the JDK it just has
this ready to go seems like something
that could have done a long time ago
with with the app with the app class
data sharing but one of the concerns
here is just cross-platform
compatibility so just you because if you
have an application that runs on one
operating system the way the class data
loading works is going to be different
than on another operating system and so
we just needed to work out the mechanics
of that so that is done all right so in
also in Java 12 we have a preview for
switch expressions so I don't know if
how familiar this kind of a ugly switch
statement is to you but we're making it
easier to write more readable switch
statements but there's one more step
from here where we can simplify that
even further using the kind of the
lambda symbol here and basically you can
get a much more readable switch so all
right so that that is coming that's a
preview that's a preview release like I
say the IDS will support this if you're
using IntelliJ you can already try that
out all right
all right and then another another
feature that's coming in Java 12 and I
got ahead of myself again earlier I'm
sorry but it's the new garbage collector
this is largely developed by Red Hat so
we have zgc shenandoah you should
experiment with those Shenandoah is is
yeah it's part of the JT camp trying to
think of something else to say alright
so JDK 13 which is scheduled for
September of this year has zero JEP so
far so which is good it may actually be
the easiest migration of any feature
release ever in the history of job I
yeah I I do suspect we will have some
some jets that will come along there but
but the but the point here is we only
target Japs when we have the features
that we know are ready and as of now we
don't have anything targeted for 13
alright so this is what I was again I
got ahead of myself I'm sorry talking
about the J Depp's tool which will help
show the package level dependencies in
your in your apps but J deeper scan
that's that's the the tool I was trying
to find earlier in my mind allows you to
scan your your apps to find deprecated
API elements that you can get a sense of
you know when you need to remove those
going forward
so one of the benefits of jigsaw in Java
9 is we are able to do these incubator
modules so we're able we're able to put
out new features in a module that's
clearly designated as incubator subject
to change subject to removal to give
people a chance to experiment with it
provide feedback and if it works out
then it'll graduate and become a
full-fledged feature otherwise it will
get removed removed and so as I
mentioned shenandoah is one in Java 12
and the switch expressions Java 12
experimental ok so let's talk a little
bit about the futures so some of the
things that are in flight but you know
we don't have a target for these you
know as a product manager of course I'm
always poking the the team to try to get
a sense of roughly when things are
coming but you know I think a good sign
of success of the new release cadence is
we don't we don't have that pressure
that we used to have before we'll
release it when it's ready and I think
it's a it's a much better way of doing
development mmm-hmm all right so these
are the these are the kind of the main
categories that were we're working on so
I mentioned this at the very beginning
containers so we we've been investing a
lot and making sure we work well in the
world of docker and kubernetes and then
performance so I showed you some slides
that showed you the performance just out
of the box the performance benefits
you'll get from going from 8 to 11 it
should just be faster and we've seen
that in the past like going from 6 to 7
it was way faster and going from 7 to 8
listen way faster but it was a little
faster and after a couple of updates
releases it was even even faster still
so when you if you go from eight to
eleven you should just automatically
another box see a performance benefit
but we're working on things to blow that
out of the park
right so there's a number of projects
that I'll talk about in that area so we
know that Java is huge in big data type
applications so we've been working hard
for a couple of years now on some data
optimization projects that I'll talk
about briefly hardware acceleration a
few years ago we had a project called
Sumatra where we were working with Oh
what was the name of that company MD I
think was it a MD I think it was a MD on
basically running Java applications
especially big data type applications on
floating oh man sorry the the jet lag is
just absolutely crushing me right now on
graphics cards video video graphics
cards right so you're able to offload
especially big data type applications
off to these floating-point graphical
units so we're seeing a resurgence in
that again so that project you know we
worked on it for a couple years we had
some third parties interested in it that
we're leading it we're starting to see
some renewed interest in that and then
of course scalability you know we see
Java running bigger and bigger
applications with larger and larger
memory demands and expectations and then
the other thing is the new release
cadence it it's great because it allows
us to do incremental changes to the
language without having these massive
changes coming every three years or so
so you're gonna see these continual
language enhancements kind of like var
right where you don't have to use it if
you don't want to but it's a it's
convenient for those that do write
so we have a number of projects with
various code names in those areas
all right so project Portola I did talk
about that a little bit at the very
beginning and again it's it's all about
working in the world of containers and
yeah so we've been working on Alpine's
so you have a download there I don't
think I have anything to add from what I
said earlier sorry project Valhalla so
the idea here with Valhalla is this is
probably a fairly common model right
where you have a data structure of key
value pairs where the the keys and the
values are just simple integers or lungs
or whatever and the way that gets laid
out in memory and the object model is it
could be better how would I put it that
way right so we can streamline that and
that's the goal of Valhalla is with
value types is there some way that we
can lay these data structures out in an
array or just you know in a straight
line rather than having to traverse the
object models right so we're gonna have
less memory but also faster access and
so that that is a project that's been
worked on for for a couple of years this
when this gets released the impact is
gonna be huge right there's going to be
a lot of applications that are just
gonna get way faster as a result out of
the box we we have a early access build
of this so you think it's based on Java
12 maybe Java 11 but you can JDK
java.net you can go and already download
some Valhalla early access builds
project Panama does anybody here have to
use j'ni no okay
lucky you so the comment I often get
when people use j'ni is it almost feels
like it was designed on purpose to be
difficult and yeah so the idea it's the
idea here with project Panama is we
realize that there are a class of
applications where it makes sense to
call out to some sort of native ahead of
time compiled library of some kind so we
see this in big data type applications
especially where you may have some you
know very low-level library that's doing
some hard poor computation that's just
been optimized in a way that a JIT can't
write and so with project Panama it'll
be easier for developers to be able to
access and leverage those low-level
libraries right so if you think about
Hadoop I don't know if many of you use
Hadoop but there's a lot of a lot of
parts of the Hadoop ecosystem that are
relying on system libraries and the j'ni
calls with the java application java
applications and of course anytime you
say big data you have to say machine
learning now - so project loom I the the
chief architect of the the fibers
project was actually a Q Khan today and
I went to a stock and it's like a whole
extra level of dimension so some of some
of this stuff the guys that are
implementing it you know it's like
multiple p1 PhD is not enough to do this
stuff perfectly right you need two PhDs
you know and when you get into this this
kind of stuff and then you combine in
some of the JIT optimizations it's not
an exaggeration that we're writing code
to generate code to generate code that
generates code
right like when you when you go all the
way down that set and and is optimizing
that code that generates the code you
know in real time so the idea hit worth
project loom is I mean you're used to
the threading model and the threading
model is great in Java but you know when
you have a bunch of blocking i/o type
things you run into scalability issues
project loom is all about dealing with
that giving you a lot more scale in how
you do your concurrent applications and
computations and it's going to be
fantastic in the world of serverless
right so this is a feature where if you
have a bunch of functions as a service
and you're architecting your
applications and kind of the FN function
style loom is going to be a huge boon to
that part of the java ecosystem
I think project loom I think we're gonna
see that fairly soon hopefully in a year
in the next year I'd say hopefully yeah
so project amber is it's a this is one
of these projects that's ongoing and
it's just always looking at language
improvements and like I said we saw a
VAR we were seeing switch expressions in
12 raw string literals was another one
that was targeted for 12 but then got
deferred and those all happen under the
project amber so if any of these
projects are interesting to you by the
way you can you can easily go find them
in the open JDK site and finally
associated wiki sign up for the mailing
list and and just keep an eye it's
always fun to even just lurk if you have
even just a small interest because you
never know when a mail might go by that
will have something interesting there
another project we have going that's
forward thinking is projects Cara and so
you know we have to remember that
working in open JDK it's not just about
the project it's not just about the JDK
but it's it's all about the
you know all the work that goes into it
so SCARA is just a project to
investigate the SEM that we're using and
again you know we've been using
mercurial a lot of people love mercurial
it has a lot of a lot of benefits but
it's clear that yet is is the most
popular and probably the easiest
platform to go to if we're looking for
broad broader participation and
experimentation of the JDK and the
builds that were working on so that is
ongoing we don't we don't have a
particular target in mind that we would
we would do that I don't did anybody
here go to open-world
or Oracle code one last year the Java
one I don't know if you saw the the
github folks were up on stage and we
actually had a demo of for those that
build build their own JD case that's
sorry that's something I might have done
at the very beginning as well as I asked
if anybody here does build their own JDK
you know there's there's a lot of
companies that do right i mean obviously
twitter does and it's what powers
twitter there's facebook and builds
their own jdk they have their own
internal builds and and they're they're
doing so mostly because they're focused
on it on a scale that's pretty niche
right a scale and volume that most
people just don't have so they so they
have that not going on but projects like
this helped companies like that that may
may be building and managing their own
jdk for their own internal use there we
go so yeah so you have early access to
those projects that I was just
mentioning I don't know why we don't
have a slide on J package but has
anybody here use J link a couple couple
people so J link is a new feature in
Java Java 9
I really should put the Java 9 features
back in this deck right then it becomes
another 20 slides long but so in Java 9
we we introduced a new feature called
j-link and this is one of the benefits
of modularity even if you're not using
modular you don't have to modularize
your applications if you don't want to
but let's say you create an application
you can use the j-link tool to strip out
the modules of the jdk that you don't
use so you can make your application
into a nice single bundle that includes
the Java Runtime only the modules your
application uses and your application
code all in a nice single little zip
file that you can chuck around the
internet or deploy on a cloud or
whatever it is you want to do with it
so that's that's J link but just in that
general topic of making it easier for
you to package and deploy your
applications we have a project called J
package where we're looking at things in
that area yeah which by the way brings
me to another common question I get with
JDK with jdk 11 is where is the JRE is
if you go to download Java 11 there's no
JRE and that can be a bit jarring but if
you haven't followed Java 9 and later
you need to understand that the the
methodology for deploying your
applications has changed
you're not deploying your applications
assuming the end user has a Java Runtime
anymore you're deploying your
applications with the Java Runtime and
that's why we have the j-link
tool that's just modern application
development right it's more and more
operating systems with with the
sandboxing rules especially if you're
looking at Mac OS we're heading to a
world where having a standalone runtime
from your application isn't going to
work anymore we need to think of these
things as a combined thing for
distribution that's how it works in
mobile
more and more we see that's how it works
in the cloud you deploy an application
to the cloud you're deploying a whole
container right so we've made that
transition in in the Java ecosystem in
the JDK starting with j-link starting
with tools like the packagers that are
coming just to make it easier for you to
package in deploy your applications and
we're just cutting the tie with cherries
I'm just saying no you need to ship your
application with with that runtime so ok
JMC
so Misha Jam see is the visualizer of
flight recorder so flight recorder
analyzes what's happening in your JVM
dumps out a bunch of raw data it's
really hard to read right so Mission
Control is a nice GUI based tool that
allows you to visualize what was
happening in your JVM so JMC builds are
there as well so open JDK java.net
that's where I'd recommend most folks go
I'm Donald o JDK if you want to follow
follow me on Twitter please do you're
also of course more than welcome to
follow any any of the other folks on the
Java platform group yeah I think that's
about it
you